nous accueillons aujourd'hui maître
stéphane handfield avocat en droit de
l'immigration est membre du barreau du
québec
bonjour je m en vais au jour mettre un
fils de nous accueillons aujourd'hui
parce que vous venez de publier un livre
chez wilson & lafleur
ce livre est intitulé immigration et
criminalité
quand l'expulsion devient inévitable
alors dans ce livre on comprend bien que
les motifs d'expulsion sont divers mais
vous vous êtes intéressé spécifiquement
à ceux liés à la grande criminalité à la
criminalité et à la criminalité
organisée et que vous nous expliquer
succinctement c'est ces trois notions
oui bah en fait c'est simple lorsqu'on
parle d'un établissement territoire pour
grande criminalité alors ce sont des
infractions qui sont passibles d'une
peine d'emprisonnement maximales d'au
moins 10 ans ça ne signifie pas que
l'individu doit être condamné pour une
peine d'emprisonnement de 10 ans merci
au code criminel par exemple
l'infraction est passible d'une peine
d'emprisonnement maximales d'au moins 10
ans on vise la grande finale tu es si la
personne peu importe la nature de
l'infraction et sans penser à une peine
d'emprisonnement de plus de six mois et
ça vise également la grande finalité au
niveau de la criminalité
c'est toute infraction au code criminel
qui est passible de la criminalité sauf
évidemment pour un résident permanent
dont on pourra embarquer plus amplement
dans l'est le volet de des différents
statuts mais la criminalité c'est
évidemment l'infraction toute
condamnation au conditionnel ou à une
loi fédérale
évidemment qu'une est organisée bon
c'est le dit c'est bon ceux qui sont
membres par exemple d'une organisation
criminelle teigne de rue mafia matin
vous avez bien fait de signaler que ces
expulsions concernent les gens qui ne
sont pas citoyens canadiens
ça concerne les résidents permanents et
autres restes as-tu dites moi une
section qui est condamné puis à les
expulser est ce qu'on n'est pas dans la
double peine c'est ce qu'on est que j'ai
tenté d'expliquer un peu par la
rédaction la publication de ce volume
c'est effectivement dans certains cas on
constate que bon
il peut y avoir certaines lacunes au
niveau du droit criminel et donc on
semble utilisé dans certains cols volet
immigration donc volée du droit de
l'immigration pour pearl pallier à ces
lacunes du droit criminel
alors évidemment je suis d'opinion que
si une personne peu importe son set et
au canada celle comme une infraction
criminelle bon doit l'arrêter l'accusé
le juger et l'a condamné le coaching par
la suite bien évidemment elle selon
écoles le volet immigration pourrait
intervenir mais je trouve que trop
souvent l'interview pour poser ce qu'on
appelle évidemment une double peine ce
avant droit criminel c'est illégal la
constitution canadienne la charte que
les années droit des libertés interdit
la dépollution de double peine
malheureusement droit des médias sans
éclat si je comprends bien l'expulsion
relève du droit de la loi sur
l'immigration et la protection la
protection des réfugiés et ne relèvent
pas du droit criminel du code criminel
parle pas du tout alors d'ailleurs celle
agence des services frontaliers du
canada qui est seul responsable du volet
expulsion d'une personne non citoyen
canadien nous quand on entend le mot
grande criminalité et puis on trouve que
c'est une personne tu peux être
condamnée à deux mois selon une
infraction qui pourrait atteindre les 10
ans a deux mois pour moi ce n'est pas de
la grande criminalité pourquoi c'est
grandvaux s'était moqué qui qui qui qui
qui font par qui et qui peut dans
certains cas semblait justement rempart
de garantie n'a été en fait sa devise
des grains criminels des meurtriers
figra trafiquants d'héroïne extra mais
pas du tout on le voit une personne qui
malheureusement commet une erreur dans
nos ports prend un verre de trop
ça peut arriver sur l'effort soit table
cette arrivée se faire effet dans un
barrage outils pas fibrés sommeil il est
accusé de conduite avec les facultés
affaiblies dans le code criminel cette
infraction est passible d'une peine
d'emprisonnement maximales d'au moins 10
nov l'individu pour une première
sentence aurore possiblement la peine
minimale quitte une amende de
dollars avec des conditions à respecter
cependant il sera filmé policiers
canadiens seront visés par une
interdiction de territoire pour grande
criminalité au canada signifie dans la
résidence permanente mesure d'expulsion
évidemment puisqu'il n'aurait pas reçu
une sentence d'emprisonnement depuis de
six mois conserverons un droit d'appel
devant la section d'appel de
l'immigration où ils pourront évoquer
entre autres motifs humanitaires ont
fait vingt trente quarante seule
condamnation
mais en mai une conduite avec facultés
affaiblies 9 cellules à mende 2000
dollars est considéré pour de la grande
criminalité
aux yeux de l'immigration donc on est
rassuré vous n'êtes pas l'avocat du
diable donc vous êtes l'avocat de deux
ore kio des droits at il mal ben
j'espère rester alors mettre un field
dans votre livre vous avait compilé
quelques quelques chiffres alors vous
dites qu'en 2018 6083 personnes ont été
expulsées du canada tous motifs
confondus et le gouvernement voudrait
même atteindre avec une cible de dix
mille personnes
quand vous l'avez bien mentionné ces
mesures sont exécutés par l' agence des
services frontaliers mais en même temps
on a des chiffres qui disent que 48
mille personnes sont recherchées par les
services frontaliers
on a l'impression que le processus peut
s'étirer et que les avocats peuvent
aussi les tirer est que à la fin il ya
des gens qui restent elles sont parties
il faut savoir que dans ce set explique
d'individus qui sont recherchés par les
services frontaliers aux expulsions
ça inclut évidemment toutes catégories
confondues pas seulement que les gens
qui sont criminalisés mais par exemple
un demandeur d'asile dont la demande a
été refusée qui ne se présentent pas au
renvoi fait parti de ces statistiques
ce qui est important aussi noté une
personne qui aurait quitté le canada
volontairement mais qu'ils n'arrêtent
pas confirmé son départ auprès d'un
agent des services frontaliers à
l'aéroport sera considéré comme étant
une personne recherchée par la passe de
services frontaliers du canada
alors ça ne signifie pas que la personne
est toujours au canada dans certains
codes des individus qui sont décédés
mais était sous le coup d'un mandat
d'arrestation donc recherché par la
police
ils sont ils amarrent toujours inclus
dans ses statistiques de personnes
recherchées pour fins de renvoi du
canada
parfait alors donc les gens qui sont
expulsés des résidents permanents et
d'autres statuts le gouvernement va les
expulser devant les expulser chez eux
mais ce chez eux n'est pas
nécessairement en dehors du canada ou du
québec par exemple si on prend le cadre
du rappeur minima qui est arrivé à 11 le
rapport minima c'est un jeune en qui à
26 ans il est d'origine algérienne il
est arrivé ici un onze ans il n'a pas eu
sa citoyenneté canadienne et il ya
beaucoup d'autres cas comme celui là que
ce chez soi se chient lui est ce que
c'est le canada est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose d'inhumain quelque part ici c'est
effectivement ce que j'ai tenté
d'expliquer par dans le biais de du
manuscrit c'est à dire que on expose un
individu ou une personne vers son pays
de citoyenneté
maintenant lorsqu'on parle de son chez
lui dans bdk ce chai je sais chimie
c'est chez eux que c'est au québec c'est
au canada en jeu faisait référence à
certains cas où les individus sont
arrivés au canada à très base argent
dans certains cols trois ans quatre ans
cinq induisant ils sont au canada depuis
30 40 50 ans ils n'ont d'emblée défaut
ils ne sont jamais retournés dans leur
pays d'origine dans le pays de
citoyenneté et malgré tout on peut les
expulser vers ce pays parce que c'est le
pays de citoyenneté alors que ils ont
vécu toute leur vie
mieux ils ont eu leurs enfants se sont
mariés ils ont leurs enfants toute leur
carrière professionnelle et au canada et
parce que bon la loi fin en soi que la
personne ayant commis des infractions
criminelles au canada perd sa résidence
permanent aux mesures d'expulsion et
dans certains spas de le ministre refuse
de façon discrétionnaire d'intervenir
pour des considérations humanitaires
part que le minet ça on ne le nie
effectivement et donc la personne se
retrouve dans bien des corps seul dans
un pays qu'elle ne connaît que ce n'est
pas son pays se son pays de citoyenneté
tout simplement c'est toujours merci
pour ces précisions m dites-moi est-ce
que l'expulsion est évitable
oui mais comme je vais le dire l'exemple
que je donnais c'est un peu le train une
fois qu'on est embarqué dans le train le
train d'écrire de la gare doit se rendre
la destination alors si on veut
l'arrêter à part le faire des rallyes
c'est très difficile donc c'est une
personne est visé par une procédure
d'interdiction de territoire pour grande
criminalité pour conclure pour kim
organisée oui il est possible de pouvoir
éviter l'expulsion
mais ça voyez vous avez écrit ce livre
quelque chose la plus difficile dans
l'écriture de ce livre sachant que c'est
un livre qui peut être lu autant par les
spécialistes que par madame et monsieur
tout le monde
ben moi pour moi c'est justement c'était
que le document soit accessible et
lorsque je dis accessible évidemment au
niveau du contenu au niveau du volume 1
joue l'effort écrire une brique de 2 300
pages
je voulais que se limiter à vraiment le
sujet nick et livia trouve la
criminalité parce que trop souvent jeu
des discussions avec des confrères ont
décriminalisé bac s qui avait une telle
situation
bon appelé à faire des formations
souvent sur le même sujet ou lors de
rencontres familiales et que c'est
expulsé alors que monsieur y nul et dans
le dépôt donc on est souvent ces
discussions là et au niveau de l'opinion
publique on est souvent confronté au
fait que ben sipa canadien c'est comme
une infraction ben qu'on l'expulsé pas
aussi simple on sait pas toujours aussi
tranchées comme situation le beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus souvent de zones
grises et c'était vraiment d'essayer de
focus est sûr question là et comme
aujourd'hui je me répète le document
soit accessible seulement aux avocats
pour seulement qu'au juge
mais monsieur madame tout le monde qui
s'intéresse à ces questions là merci m e
stéphane handfield je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat en droit de l'immigration
est membre du barreau du québec merci
d'avoir c'est une invitation et fait
plaisir